Memphis on edge this morning.
The city is bracing
for the release of police body
cam video of officers beating
Tyre Nichols,
a traffic stop that turned deadl
We're also waiting to see
if the officers involved will fa
criminal charges.
And I have a warning for you.
We're about to show you a photo.
This is a photo of Terry Nichols
in his hospital bed before he di
Now, Nichols
family has already seen
the body cam footage.
They say it is horrific
and they're demanding murder cha
The family's attorney says
that the officers
beat Tyree
nonstop like a human pinata
for several minutes.
CNN's Sara Sidner following this
for us from Memphis this morning
Sara, good morning to you.
They're bracing for this video
of the chief herself condemning
what happened to Tyree.
This is just an awful story
all the way around. It is.
And because we have not seen the
and I think
because the public has not seen
the video,
there is great concern here
about what the response is going
But we do know
that this was a vicious attack
really on the part of these
five officers.
And there are a lot of questions
We heard from community members
who told us that they are worrie
this place is going to blow
But the thing that is tempered
some of this is the police
chief's reaction
that she quickly reacted.
She fired the officers
and the community
and the family are demanding cha
And those two things
may tamp down emotions to see
that something is finally being
In this case,
The Memphis
police chief
speaks out in a recorded stateme
making clear
there will be absolute accountab
for those responsible
for the death of 29 year
old Tyree Nichols.
This is not just a professional
This is a failing of basic human
toward another individual.
This incident was heinous, reckl
and inhumane.
Nichols died earlier
this month
after a violent arrest by five o
five Memphis
police officers
and two members
of the Memphis Fire Department
have been terminated.
Nichols family is calling for ch
to be filed as the community
anxiously awaits the police came
footage to be released.
The family wants nothing but the
most charge that they that they
and what they want are murder ch
Attorneys for the family
have already viewed the footage
and an independent autopsy
paid for by the family
reveals Nichols died
from, quote,
extensive bleeding
caused by a severe beating.
I hate the bait that
because it's black people.
We're out here killing each othe
to away from I don't know why
what happened to the humanity
and kindness. That's right.
Nichols was a driver for FedEx.
He'll be remembered as a loving
and son.
The baby of the family
with a tattoo of his mother's
name on his arm.
Nobody's perfect, okay?
Nobody.
But he was damn near.
My son was a beautiful soul.
He liked to go to Starbucks most
where he befriended
an unlikely group of people.
One of those friends tells CNN
Nichols was a free spirited pers
a gentleman
who marched to the beat of his o
He enjoyed skateboarding
and taking pictures of sunsets.
A friend who knew Nichols in Sac
said this of him.
He was his own person and didn't
He didn't fit
into what a traditional black ma
was supposed to be in California
He had such a free spirit and sk
gave him his wings.
For this to happen to him in thi
that pain is just
this is
I have no words
So we also heard from the police
who said that
the reason
for the firing of the officers
was use of excessive
force duty to intervene
they failed to do that
and duty to render aid.
There is a big question
about these two members
of the fire department,
because if they were
there as emergency services,
their duty is not to enforce the
it is to save lives.
The question is, why were they f
Because if they were there to sa
and that is not what they did,
they didn't take part
That leaves
a really nasty taste in people's
And I just want to mention to yo
that last night
I was able to go into the church
where they are going to have the
for Terry on Wednesday.
And the senior pastor of the Met
Boulevard, Christ
Christian Church
said that their hearts are so he
after sort of hearing
about all of the details of this
And he's very worried
about how the community
is going to respond
but they have been trying
to be there for the community
so that they have an outlet
for their emotions.
Yeah.
There's a reason
why they're waiting
to release this video
where they're being so cautious
And I think
they're giving people
time to absorb that.
It is going to be emotional.
And as you said, horrific.
Vicious, I think. What were your
So we'll see.
And then
to get some answers,
not only on the beating,
but also why
these two members of the fire de
That's very important.
Sara Sidner has been covering th
and she'll continue.
Thank you, Sara. Appreciate that
So want to turn now
to the looming release of this v
showing a man being beaten by po
which preceded his death.
So joining us now,
the executive director
of the Memphis ACP, Vikki Terry.
She met with the members of the
I'm so glad that you could join
because you know the people invo
You met with the family,
you know the police chief.
You have been a member of the co
for a long time.
And you're the executive directo
the perfect person to talk about
So I just have to get
some information from you.
We have heard that
possibly the officers
are going to surrender.
Do you know anything about that,
if you heard that? I have alread
And I'm thinking
that that is going to happen.
And sometime
today, Do you have any idea of w
Around 10:00 a.m.
around 10:00 SWAT at the Memphis
Memphis Central
Time would be 11 eastern that th
So listen overnight.
And you know, the chief
you know, Chief S.J.
Davis, she spoke out for the fir
about this and gave a very,
very important statement.
I want to play it
and I want to get your response
Thank you.
I expect you to feel outrage
in the disregard of basic human
as our police officers have take
to do
the opposite of what
transpired on the video.
I expect our citizens to exercis
their First Amendment right
to protest, to demand action and
But we need to ensure
our community is safe in this pr
So being a member of
a long time
member of the community,
have you ever heard
the police chief
come out and do something like t
No, I have not since he's been h
But I think she told me
that that was something
that she wanted to do,
to let the people know
how horrified she was of this pl
I think that's going to say
that speaks to the nature of
what's in this video.
What are you being told is in th
I spoke to the family members.
I have.
But I didn't go into too much de
because of technicalities.
So they did not want the communi
to know until it's been released
But the fact that the chief is c
and saying this
they're taking their time
and releasing the statement,
which I feel
they're preparing the community
what's to come,
because otherwise, if they were,
they would release it.
If it wasn't so bad,
if in some way
that was questionable
about what happened
or if it exonerated the officers
in any way
with the fact that they're waiti
and they're being careful about
speaks to the nature of exactly
But what are you hearing is in t
what it's like?
I mean, I heard it was worse
than the Rodney King video,
if I could say that much.
So if
we could go back
and think about
what happened years ago to Rodne
It's worse than that.
And I've heard even
Ben Crump say that this is proba
one of the worst things
that he's at, the violence
that he's seen.
When you
spoke to the family members,
what is the sentiment?
What are they saying?
And how are they doing?
They want justice for their son.
And they just
you know,
I think some of the last words
he said was, what did I do?
What did I do?
And that mother was just saying,
you know, what did my son do?
What could he have done to deser
what Arabic he got?
Yeah.
I just wonder, you know, they sa
the family wants justice,
but they believe that
there should be murder charges
for these five officers. Yes, si
That is right.
That is correct.
That is what they are asking the
to do,
charge them with first degree mu
The fact that the officers are a
what does that say to you?
You heard me.
You heard my heart.
I was very, very upset when I he
Of course, I mean, regardless an
But just to have five
African-American officers to do
young man that wait list and I d
He only weighed £145 with them,
five of them to
savagely beat him.
And he was over six feet tall,
but he had Crohn's disease right
So he didn't weigh a lot
because of the illness.
He was yeah,
he was tall and and slight in st
But the fact that there are five
and they're all black,
I've heard one member,
a prominent member of the commun
but they're all blue
meaning they're all police offic
and they all had the same traini
That's right.
And I don't think this has anyth
to do with the training.
I think just like Police Chief
Davis said, they are trained ver
But the mentality
that they took on that night,
I think there was
a personal decision that they ma
so I don't think they had anythi
to do with the training.
What do you say to the community
this fear of unrest?
There is, and I think if
it happens today
and if the charges are,
you know, brought to the officer
if it's not what the Alabama tea
thinks should happen, there migh
You're worried.
Are you worried?
I'm not I am not worried right n
I'm just praying that, you know,
it will be a peaceful protest.
Whatever happens, I hope it's pe
Victory.
We thank you for your insights
and appreciate
you waking up early to come down
Oh, yeah. Thank you. Thank you s